♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JOHN JAMES IS A
REPUBLICAN IN MICHIGAN AND HE IS
CHALLENGING DEBBIE STABENOW IN
THE STATE.
A77 YEARS OLD AND FLEW
HELICOPTERS DURING THE IRAQ WAR.
HE'S BEEN UNDERDOG FOR THE
ENTIRE RACE BUT POLLS NOW SHOW
HIM WITHIN STRIKING DISTANCE OF
THE INCUMBENT SENATOR.
WE THINK ALL OF THAT MIGHT MAKE
AN INCUMBENT NEWS STORY BUT THE
PRESS HAVE LARGELY IGNORED JAMES
WHILE TURNING BETO O'ROURKE INTO
A CELEBRITY.
WHY IS THAT?
THAT'S A QUESTION.
WE DON'T OFTEN HAVE CANDIDATES
ON, BUT JOHN JAMES JOINS US.
MR. JAMES, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THE REASON WE WANTED TO TALK TO
YOU, WE WANT TO PLAY FOR OUR
VIEWERS A RECORDING THAT YOU
MADE.
IT'S A REPORTER THAT CALLED YOU
AND YOU ANSWERED AND SHE THOUGHT
SHE HUNG UP BUT SHE DIDN'T AND
HERE'S WHAT YOU CAPTURED ON
TAPE.
>> MY NUMBER IS 989 [BLEEP]
EXTENSION ONE OH NINE.
MAN, IF HE BEATS HER, THAT WOULD
SUCK.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL HAPPEN.
HE'S HARD TO GET A HOLD OF.
I HOPE HE DOESN'T WIN FOR THAT
REASON, TOO.
>> DO YOU HAVE A TOP STORY?
>> Tucker: SO THAT IS BRENDA
BATTLES, A REPORTER FROM A LOCAL
NEWSPAPER AND I GUESS SHE
DOESN'T LIKE YOU.
IS THAT YOUR READ ON THAT?
>> John: I WOULD SAY SO.
I THINK THIS IS JUST KIND OF THE
INDICATION THAT YOU ARE, THE
UPHILL BATTLE THAT MANY OF US
ARE FACING BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
BIAS THAT WE ARE SEEING OUT
THERE IS JUST NOT FAIR FOR THOSE
WHO SHARE DIFFERENT OPINIONS
THAN SOMEONE IN THE PROGRESSIVE
LIBERAL MEDIA.
>> Tucker: IS KIND OF ON
DISPLAY THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOUR SHOT IS
TOMORROW >> John: WE CLOSE THE
GAP BY OUR GRASSROOTS ARMY, AND
IN THE NEXT ROOM WE HAVE A RALLY
GOING ON WITH A COUPLE HUNDRED
PEOPLE BACK THERE WHO ARE FIRED
UP ABOUT GETTING THE VOTE HERE
IN MICHIGAN.
I WILL TELL YOU, WE HAVE THE
ENERGY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SICK
AND TIRED OF BEING CONDESCENDED
TO END THE INEFFECTIVENESS AND
HYPERPARTISANSHIP OF DEBBIE
STABENOW.
PEOPLE WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT TAKES TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
VETERANS AND KEEP THIS COUNTRY
SAFE.
THEY WANT TO CREATE JOBS IN THE
REAL WORLD, SOMEBODY WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO GROW OUR
ECONOMY AND THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN.
THE LIBERAL BIAS THAT YOU ARE
SEEING, THAT YOU JUST HEARD FOR
YOURSELF RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN, ARE INTENT ON
MAINTAINING THE STATUS QUO.
BECAUSE I DON'T FIT IN ANYONE'S
LOCKBOX OR A LITTLE WHITE BOX.
OUR LITTLE RED BOX OR LITTLE
BLUE BOX.
I'M RED, WHITE, AND BLUE.
AND WHEN I GET TO WASHINGTON I'M
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MOVE
THIS DATE FORWARD AND WE MOVE
THIS COUNTRY FORWARD AND WE ARE
NOT GOING TO LET ANYBODY STOP
US.
IT'S ABOUT KEEPING AMERICA SAFE
AND IT'S ABOUT PUTTING MICHIGAN,
NUMBER ONE.
>> Tucker: I WAS WONDERING
WHY -- WE'VE BEEN HEARING SO
MUCH ABOUT BETO O'ROURKE AND
NOTHING ABOUT YOU AND NOW WE
KNOW WHY.